you
hi everyone is Gerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer when it tried three more
puzzles
first one playing as black okay my first
thought is that we have to do something
quick because white is able to give
check and continual checks over here on
the e87 squares so forcing moves Queen
here's my first thought
there's also rook here hmm Queen check
on d3 seems very appealing the Queen is
quite deep in the white position
controlling a lot of squares
and one more hmm the rook could block
there is no Queen be one the Queen has
that
um what about Queen here however Queen
to a4
going to a four that is maybe a bit more
appealing even though this is deeper in
the Y position I'm not sure the follow
up after rook d3 Brook here hmm
Queen a4 if King here battle lose to a
matin to actually if Queen a for king d2
there would follow queen d4 King II won
rook c1 is made the Queen from the d4
square covers f2 and all of these D file
squares so after Queen a for King here
and then well there's a lot you could do
I don't know about a lot let's see Queen
a for King here what would be the
follow-up probably check up check on
Siwon King f2 and now there's both
Bishop and Queen that could be giving
check on d4 with the rook on c1 the way
King on f2
I would be thinking more about queen of
D for Queen D for check yeah that's
probably gonna be picking up this rook
without this rook around these checks
over here by the Queen probably don't
amount to anything at all the best white
could hope for would be a perpetual so
I'm pretty sure it's this Queen a for
King d1 rook c1 check
King f2 queen d4 if the rook blocks
there's rook c2 and then capturing the
rook on the e3 to follow I believe it's
important after Queen check King here
rook c1 check King f2 to not just grab
the rook because of these checks over
here the coordination that white has on
the e7 and e8 squares I'm just gonna run
with this one that is correct
pretty sure this yeah that's as far as
it goes
let me just double check here with the
analysis board let's make sure I'm right
on with that so if after Queen check
King here rook check King f2 what is it
saying at that point that doesn't even
go into anything but I'm pretty
confident that it would be I bring this
up one more time should have closed out
I'm pretty sure after this continuation
Queen check King here rook check after
King here Queen check and we're gonna be
winning this rook like if brick blocks
there's this followed by Queen takes
rook or if King here then we have this
Bishop check and if the King moves over
here now we take this rook with check
this is the one thing I was saying it's
important maybe not to do and that is
after just this check King here to just
grab the rook because of these things
and black is probably getting mated yeah
something like this somehow or another I
think I have that right anyhow um I only
went two moves deep with this one real
check here I think it should have been
carried out maybe one more to know that
this is probably the the winning
continuation but okay let's just dive
right in try the second one two of three
ooh very simplified position so okay the
white pawns are very close to queening
and there it is the mascot the Beagle
enters right on cue right on cue that
beagle is all right so if we push right
away rook takes pawn and then rook takes
pawn black will be able to hold this so
the idea I'm assuming is going to be to
make sure we could queen and have that
Queen and Queen and King versus rook and
King ending so what would be the first
move pretty sure it's not this
f7 just take here if white really wants
to make sure they could hold this to a
draw that's easily done with bringing
the King over to f7 and then pushing hmm
I wonder about
hmm King to e8 King to e8 with the idea
when you push f7 then the rook when it
takes the pawn the pawn won't be pinned
to the king so this is this is pretty
much my first idea King to EA but there
can then follow king to e6 hmm tricky
let's see King to e8 King to e6 I'm not
sure there's a way to improve the rook
position so that's why I'm suggesting
after King to e8 just leave the rook has
is and play King to e6 King e8 King e6
f7 and then if rook takes pawn you
promote on f8 with the Queen
however after King e8 King e6 f7 the
black king is boxing out the white king
when the King is on e 8 and the black
king is on e6 so there might be an
opportunity for the rook to switch back
over and try to give a back rank mate
King EA King e6 f7 and let's say rook a1
now it becomes a little bit tricky
because if we're promoting this pawn to
anything but a knight because a knight
promotion would be with check from
promoting to anything but at night we're
gonna get mated with rook to e8 King e8
King e6 f7 rook takes pawn we promote
successfully
so can you a King e6 f7 rook a one let's
say hmm there's a pawn on f7 a king on
EA can East six four black Y King is on
e 8 g8 is doing nothing the pawn is in
the way of giving some check so could we
promote to a night like this with check
and then King f6
attacking the pond that's not see that
working out because whatever you promote
to next you could still do I know that
is working what am I talking about that
is working okay King EA King e6 f7 rook
a1 you promote to a knight you give
check and if the King goes to any of
these squares then there's no more issue
of some back rank mate you could promote
successfully for some reason I was
thinking the rook is gonna give check
and grab that promoted piece let's let's
run with this I'm pretty sure it's it is
correct King e6 now f7 and hopefully the
computer does do something like that it
is so now this is key promote to a
knight with check and now we get a queen
and that's it yeah for some reason I was
blind in my in trying to visualize that
I was blind to this rook check thinking
when the King moves the Queen is going
to be lost but there's that night that's
in between ok let's try this last one 3
of 3 hmm I feel like I've seen this one
before
Queen check here is my first thought
Queen to g6 and well we better have
something good here right because of
these checks over here on h1
although there's not a great follow-up
after rip check on each one so when I
see that when I see maybe potential
counter counter moves by the opposing
side here if the checks kind of run out
which I believe they do
rook h1 King f2 there's not a good
follow up next for black then that maybe
leaves a window open for some quiet move
by some quiet move by white on maybe
this move or after like some checking
move and then a quiet move so queen g6
King here maybe there's maybe there's
some quiet move at that point fact there
might be something connected with Bishop
takes f6 and move one not the not the
most quiet move to start with it's not
giving check but the two of the three
ways that there are two capture Queen
takes would be met with Queen g8 mate
King takes would be met with Queen g6
mate and pawn takes can be met with well
it's Queen check on d7 for one and one
more let's see Bishop takes pawn rook
check King f2 they run out it's still
the same story king or queen taking on
this square is gonna be mate it's very
windy outside wow I don't know if you
could hear that oh you definitely could
hear that there's some there's some I
think I just thought total flyby there's
some tornados that are maybe right
around the corner some fun little fact
here well that record versus the Beagle
we're not hearing the Beagle but we're
hearing a potential tornado okay this
might be the last video I ever do okay
Bishop takes pawn pawn takes that's what
I'm trying to figure out as mother
nature's too
it's getting loud um Bishop takes pawn
let's just say a check is turning king
f2 pawn takes Bishop Wow
pawn takes Bishop and at the very least
you could do a perpetual check Bishop
takes pawn pawn takes oh boy I feel like
just dropping this one I feel like just
running with this one let's try it yes
it's correct
okay and now Queen check here it's gotta
be this isn't leading to anything let's
just go with that perpetual check that's
all this is I always draw this time of a
perpetual check those are something more
than I'm missing I'm not seeing what
more there would be I think it's just
perpetual is that it yeah perpetual what
a silly way to end all right I better um
better make sure everything's okay here
the power is probably gonna go out very
quickly but um okay those are the only
three that I was going to do and wasn't
really a big fan of this last one but
what can you do
alright well anyhow I hope you got
something out of this video and I'll
hopefully catch you in the next video
take care
night check here pawn takes Bishop g2
are you kidding me